whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up the state
of Nevada were teaching someone how to
apply makeup can get you fine 2,000
bucks if you don't have a state license
and then there's this you would not
think giving away a free bottle of water
would get so in trouble but a city of
phoenix code enforcer threatened dana
crow Smith with a citation for handing
out free bottled water to people in 112
degree heat I think anybody should be
able to give away water it's hot but
there can be only one nanny of the month
and this time it's Secretary of Health
and Human Services Kathleen Sebelius hHS
has doled out some serious grant money
to cities to support prevention and
wellness but as Jeff's Tiger points out
the money was also used to push for
local nanny state laws like soda taxes
and anti fast food zoning ordinances
stimulus money funded the grants the
more recently it was Obamacare dough
sibelius defends the grants but HHS
inspector general thinks they may
reflect inappropriate lobbying
activities that violate federal law
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding your own business